welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name's Hisham azuz today I'm
very excited to finally be joined by
Chris sheds and if you don't know
Christians he is the founder of sr2
which stands for socially responsible
recruitment and they are a tech
specialist agency that based in Bristol
can't me have 18 people in the business
and have been going for just over two
and a half years but for those of you
that don't know quite a while go now I
did a podcast with one of Chris's
business partners at least at Eagle as
well so Chris good to finally have your
mate
alright be on thank ya it's good really
excited for this I really do feel like
Chris the a lot of people particularly
the Bristol world would love to know a
bit more about the back story if I
started I feel like because I think it's
safe to say that you guys are a brand
that people know about in Bristol from a
recruitment perspective which is a
really good thing so I guess first
things first Chris we're always like to
start how did how did Shirdi end up in
hydrographer I guess I understand
everyone else like you fall into it any
- I was my kind of career path was going
to be a professional golfer that was my
kind of alien ambition and I had kind of
from childhood friends of them a good
knowledge of ramana who's know Andy
about this and he was working at time
with s3 I was kind of trying to become a
program for teaching people but
ultimately spending loads of time and a
crappy little shop selling my clothes
and he was like I was working weekends
II was kind of burning loads of money
and it was just like that's kind of how
the entry got so heated air recommend
the friends to s3 and so kind of he
prepped me to the nines I did an
interview with them just going back a
long time I like 2007 and I got
absolutely hammered for like 6 hours in
an s3 interview back at like four or
five different stages as you see in
Brisbane
yeah and Bristol yeah if I look back now
I cringe and what were they cut me free
but and was
and his pen and light like say yeah yes
I slugged me across the table and one of
them did like a car showroom like roll
placing with me and when I just like
proper trying to trip you up a pen and
then I kind of what audit went in
because basically long photo shows that
for like six hours and then I didn't get
the job at the end and and the kind of
feedback was that coming from my golf
industry into like an office based
industry let alone kind of never even
done a commensal fried was too much of a
gap so they basically said you were very
close we suggested go away get some
telesales experience for six months and
then come a-knockin on tour again so I
did exactly that so kind of quit the
golf thing went to insurance sales for
like six six months of the day and just
fell in like a car it was a car at home
insurance so that's why then yeah and
then and it really really because I was
obviously super transactions up yeah
Matthew just purely on price like I'm
gonna tickets they're like I was hungry
just at a point to prove to get back to
my everyone else was just plod along
literally six months to the day it was
they emailed in my sales figures was top
of the board I was like right consider
me now and I got the job
second time around basically but in that
in that part in that six months and we
go in there
Nigel had left that three and gone and
tomorrow at the paranoid did get a job
and my sis made it so what was at that
point then where you like sales is
something that I actually like the idea
of I was like oh my the appeal at a time
was probably the money and yes I said I
was earning my proper peanuts in the
gold say I was the like then someone's
got a month or something I worry for
working lately living at home and stuff
and so it's probably initially the money
and I kind of went into unease and not
reading and what it was all about in
truth yes and something that hasn't been
told probably initially the money if
another okay so I'm just just a frame
art then so first job on recruitment for
one of the sort of most renowned brands
and had a lot of people that worked s
free on this podcaster so really speak
highly of the unique culture that they
created and these
lots of things so everyone listening so
your first German crewman was there and
you how long did you work there for
about 10 11 months in the end ok 10 11
months not a year and then I said and
then after that join diverse yeah the
basically my my direct manager Buck
O'Brien speed is those direct estilo
because he kind of was my mentor when I
started 3 or futures say he kind of kind
of grab a pencil that I'm going on your
opportunity and I'm kind of like to
bring you this on relatedly yeah so I I
kind of bar to do okay so it's a
frame-up then so 11 months s free and
then and then how many years was it opus
it six years and then round about four
years at Randstad after that and before
you sell sr2 yeah
so pretty much there's like 10 11 years
of working employed as a biller as a
recruiter building manager whatever
before you start this are - yeah okay so
let just a few key thing like for me I
really want to dig into sort of the two
and a half year journey so far I'm in
SRT but just just a few things so first
things first have to ask you what what
what's your opinion looking back into
what that culture was like at s free
what were the sort key things that stuck
with you on and back now that had a big
impact on you I think for me but back in
the day back then s 3 was like well
known as being another best for training
so I think obviously there's loads and
loads of businesses Otis Darren was at
XS three modes of people in the numbers
and so in loads of other businesses
recruitment has kind of spun up from big
from s3 so they were always really well
renowned for training yeah and suddenly
a general gist was go there earn your
stripes and people would either spin out
their own companies and try a little bit
more money or go out for an impact
mission so the appeal from me was the
kind of training aspect and getting the
kind of building blocks but the culture
was the stylized stuff you you would
cringe at some of the stuff he to go on
by just not shave there like she went in
with a beard it was like there's the bit
my going to stand yeah if you ask them
if
like a pocket on your digital t-shirt
and my environment you got a pocket on
your share was like right what about
here but like in terms of light other
now because a lot of people say sort of
the things that I learned there is stuff
that I've used now and like just really
speak highly of just basically what's
really been common is that the standards
or like this the standards that everyone
sort of work towards and held themselves
to were extremely high which encourage I
want to level up their game and that
that's a sort of a common thing that's
come out of there when we spoken about
ya hundred standards and quality of
everything that goes on I think if I
lift it from the business now for me and
exactly again what was done previously
it's like the vertical market focus
having your niche yeah and a number of
postcodes he's focused on that's like
tried and tested in pretty much any
successful human business and that's the
new policy where I love that and that
stage of me throwing them with anything
could do anything different than that
okay what those Shana so so when you
then Norse you join opus which again
obviously from from what I don't know
the whole story but in terms of Bristol
opus in terms of recruitment market in
Bristol what I feel like opus go hand in
hand in that in terms it was typically a
business that you think of and so I
guess on the openness journey then was
it the typical route of joining their
with the years experience and then just
sort of climbed up the ranks to sort of
a leader role was you then leading a
team by the time you left yeah exactly
that yeah we started day one there's
literally about five six of us and
literally starting it from ground zero
really on a day the day we open the
doors yet no one actually starting it
from day one and Darren the owners kind
of aim and ambitions always to grow it
really fast so I think even in my in my
six years we've grown from four or five
of us up to over a hundred similar like
the other now like plus two under
different countries and stuff like that
so yeah 2012 I went to London and opened
the first office or the second office
for APIs the first office outside of
Bristol yeah as I experienced love just
I didn't like London basically so the
day minimum mr. Bristow and then it was
kind of I washed my options now
basically okay so just equivalent then
what what what I'm keen to just so get
your thoughts on and then the my Bishop
things that go into this but what what
I'm always interested to know is sort of
why why Chris shared got the
opportunities he did in a grown business
when no doubt competition is high loads
of people coming in into the business it
was growing so I guess what I'm always
interested in I'd like to think a lot of
people that listen to this one to be the
best versions of themselves want to
maximize their recruitment career so I'm
just always interested on sort of Chris
during the business for five people and
then it's grown 200 or so by the time
you left
why did you manage to climb the ranks or
why did you manage to sort of get those
opportunities where you've got to open
an office experience that what what made
you get those opportunities do you think
I think being a founder definitely
helped and having that ambition I think
because because we grew so fast when I
was probably asked to do things far
quicker than you would and then normal
by the more established company so like
reality I was managing people after
certainly could be 12 months office
because it was like we need someone to
manage all these people that's coming in
so we all had to kind of step up to be
la implemented far quicker than you
normally would so I think I had a
certain interest I was far more
interested in doing that but I was just
sitting there and billion and making
loads of money so that was always the
case yeah yeah yeah I've no other way
I've always kind of been far more
motivated by seeing other people get
success than opening was myself I was a
steady bill I was never like that
superstar I got the principal over
switch after Dichter undecayed to do in
twelve months but I was I have to get a
calculator out to make sure I hit
[Laughter]
straight there was like yeah I've done
that easily yeah yeah that was kind of
I've got to certain level of principle
and the next step ID just get your heads
on a bill and maybe get resources in and
be more or you go down the management
breeze but by that point I wasn't
managing any way but but you kind of
have to in a fast growing business yeah
sure was kind of okay
so maybe this can also relate to SR to
maybe even your time that Randstad then
but I think a real challenge and is that
sort of transition from bill into
management so I guess I'm sure you
learned a lot during that or through
that a trance dad or even now or and
open what where this what was looking
back some of the key learnings on that
then because I think that's a real
challenge for a lot of builders that
find themselves in the management role
what are some of the things you found
difficult or you learned during that
period yeah I think number one you kind
of mentioned find yourself in a
management writing to too often as
everyone knows in our industry just
because you're a good village does not
mean you're going to be a good manager
so we have seen people that kind of
could be relatively average at billing
could be great managers and so I think
time management is always the obvious
one so it's kind of you've got to be
really rigid in terms of protecting that
time but I think from a certain business
owner point of view and the things that
I've learned over time is kind of having
a realistic number of people that that
person can manage before something up to
give so being a hands-on biller and then
growing a team around you and still
being expected to do once you've seen it
like seven eight plus people it's almost
something's gotta give some wear the
wrong size of the support to the team or
it's your own Billings and compromise
you there so I can particularly as we've
grown s or to even really conscious of
that balance and what added value that's
interesting even understand okay for
that I think that the key left mister
was just time management yeah okay cool
so and what one let's get into s are to
them because or understand Randstad
sorry another big brand and and you
weren't there for was it freeing a bit
years right you said yeah for in our
here three and half years and then was
that just a straight management role or
is it billion or and so I I left first
after success about I came back from
London and looked at whatever
Tennessee's were and then started to
kind of get me at the edge to kind of
settle in business by nearly I left
office for the intention of staying at
my own business with my friend Oaks at
the time and things didn't work out and
I was kind of left in a position where
like what is my next moves going to be
to it was either going
sat on my own and continued the route
that kind of plans with my friend and
but I'd be on my own
and obviously contracture can take
kennel from Osama bin at for six years
though yes that was one option and I've
just kind of weight up what my other
options were if I went to a different
agency so Ram stub is obviously huge
massive corporate company I've worked
for starved for six years there's a
sales manager role oversee the whole
office and risks when they had the
London Tech operation and Bristol wasn't
necessary doing as well as they would
want it to which they're quite
transparent about so for me it was a
case of I've got the opportunity to
maybe almost prove to myself at that
time but I could run a whole office
permanent contract but without the risk
with it being on run says money in
supposed to - actively so yeah so how
many people did you leave so grew it at
Pete I think about thirty-eight people I
started with about ten I drop that down
to five pretty much and then grew that
back up from five to thirty eight in
about two and a half years really yes it
was a canal journey and quite a rapid
but available today at the cash flow to
do it yeah okay let's just talk about
that for a sec and then we'll segue into
sr2 you just sort of learnings on on the
the leadership side which i think people
will get value out of what besides
obviously aired the cash that you just
mentioned of course I'm assuming the
brand helped as well but how what were
some of the key factors that enable you
to sort of grow the numbers by that do
you think I guess is a very different
beast so it is a corporate company so
are not a taller corporate person so I
think personally it took some adjustment
to get from a startup has a greater
capacity was at times and it was kind of
your flying brothers to see if he pumps
a little bit just holding on as it grew
so quickly whereas it was a lot of
slower paced in month dozen of corporate
kind of machine that took a bit turning
to get it kind of where we needed to get
super I think the aim and my task was
always to kind of turn it around and
about growing it quite aggressively so
that was always the fun of the brief
that I had to do but I was probably
first
six months of analyzing who I inherited
what a business was what was good what
was bad what I needed to change the etc
and before we could grow it but they
were the managing Dutch I was reporting
into kind of gave me complete carte
blanche to do what I wanted at that
business that was a complete change of
culture complete change of personnel for
the people that were in that business it
gone from an account Blair's quite stay
all business ultimately and I was trying
to reinvent it into a new business kind
of 360 contrast and poem type
environment from showing new business
generation LEDs so there were a lot of
people have been there for some like 20
years or part of the furniture there and
I was trying to come in as he come over
you know trying to do trying to teach
and new tricks so it was an interesting
experience but a really positive
experience in terms of my own and kind
of great yeah I mean it seems yeah it
seems like obviously you had it in mind
you want to start your own business so
it seems like you just ended up taking
the sort of the great really great path
fun learning from in a startup growing
business grew quickly billing then
leading and then you've got the
experience and I'm joining a sort of big
corporate the way that you just
described it there so I guess so I guess
it seems like you sort of soaked up some
great experience to sort of give you the
confidence to go right SR to that this
is sort of how I'm going to do it
learning from what I did and so just
before we go into that what what would
you what would you say that the the main
difference is then and working for
corporate compared to a business like
office or business like you are now
would you say like pros and cons would
you say and probably like pro a hundred
percent of the factors by Darren was in
the office is always very present the
owner of that business whereas you
compare over the corporate even though
our sales manager running that whole
office
it was very top-down so some like those
examples I could give you where all of a
sudden you get announced are nowhere
that you're changing the Commission
structure and you've got a roll out so
everyone and I'm looking at it single an
underground this video this is not a
good change of commission structure like
people are going to leave and it's yeah
you know you can deliver it in the best
possible way you can and try and
some sort of shine on it if I think
things like that and one of my
co-founder Steve Roberts is exactly that
he took him into the business a trans
does he was my stop turn Billa groaning
might develop him to be just a bit a
machine he was and change the Commission
structure and he was completely
hamstrung it was too would have cost him
thousands and he left the business yeah
so yeah I think just think I'm a up no
dude I have any control of your own
destiny basically way I think with the
short with a smaller company you can
have at least a conversation if those
hub changes need to be made then if we
she can have a give your opinion on them
should we say it and maybe have some
impact on the decision whereas you've
got no chance in the courtroom okay
interesting so okay so and then in terms
of so let's talk about the journey that
you've been over the sort of last two
and a half years what what did you make
sure that you wanted to have in place or
do or had planned that sort of you
learnt from it not quite working out of
your friend previously or what you would
sort it from as don't notice whatever
what what was sort of the the things you
wanted the non-negotiables for you when
approaching or planning on Stan SR to
then that you made sure they've gotten
place and I think I was quite granular
in terms of detail and the things that I
wanted in place um I was very clear like
for example when I started at well we
had the same issues because sometimes it
even from like a technology point of
view like I remember we were on like the
worst internet ever when I started with
run stars we had like ten people when we
scaled it's like 30 people there brought
the internet it wouldn't it wouldn't
wasn't good enough there's not even like
tiny little details of making sure
everything was in the right place and we
had everything we needed to to be
successful but the structure that we use
now within us is no different in reality
to what without an s3 in terms of that
vertical market focus niche in terms of
individuals both geographically and
converting within IT so the market
structure in terms of what each
individual's going to be doing was the
same working in a corporate was very
kind of KPI driven so it's very numbers
generated it was all
gaston alpha alfalfa numbers numbers
numbers and regardless of kind of what
story was behind master that that's
never been me as ever to me I kind of
believed in and so there's lots of
things I've learned that I know I didn't
want to do yes kind of things I wanted
to avoid for sure and because ultimately
is just a fundamentals of trying to
create a business that I would want to
work for myself so those things that run
that did very well those things that I
first did very well in each there was
things that maybe I would necessarily
agree with it was kind of important I
wouldn't want to do and in sr2
effectively but also me sugar back it
trying to create a business that I would
want to work in myself yeah and I think
that's really common isn't it so I guess
who said then and then just give me a
bit of context or people listening and
then is it this is a business it you
didn't start on your own right or did
you um I I was honest kind of three
months notice it so when I left runs dad
I obviously had their missions to set it
up so one sides gone and in that time
period after I'd gone Steve had already
left as I said to the kind of top
permeability gone past me as though I've
had conversation names that look I'm
thinking of son I'm in business would be
interested he was and once I've gone a
couple of others of quite a few others
had left rancid in that time as well two
of which lesion astonished Alicia who
used have only progress previously she
was my first tire of the start to do the
rebuild at runs up and Nathaniel was my
second time that honey works alongside
that Leisha previous company so those
were kind of three people that I'd
worked with for the best part of two and
a half three years I trusted then we
worked very well together and you were
that kind of strengths and weaknesses
were so when we open the doors all SRT
on day one there was or pretty much
within the first couple of weeks there
was no it's four of us there as kind of
co-founders that all knew what we doing
all knew each other only stunts mean it
sound really good really good solid
start in terms of the quality of people
we had in the business to really get it
going from ok an early stage and and and
how and then like how this a lot I think
and then back to sort of the point of
wanting to build a business that you
wanted to work for what was the Chris
plan on building a business that had an
on
fair advantage over your competitors
like what what was a differentiator here
or what was your plan on how are you
planning on making your agency to be
different I got my the inspiration for
kind of socially something real quick
just literally by reading a book on
holiday so then on holiday we in the
book called people over profit by those
with Dale archers and he accepted me
otherwise wanted to have my own agency
but the kind of concerts or the USDA
that I'd never been kind of completely
clear until I read that book so he the
author range of business could 7li which
sells apparel for charity they changed
the cherry every seven days they create
t-shirts for these widow charities name
on they sell at seven percent of that
profit goes back to the charity and they
switch every seven days new and citizen
American business very very popular very
successful also generates a lot of money
for charity so I just read the book and
was like lovely ideal of the concept and
then my brain just started working thing
and how can I translate that concept
into what I liked in which is I see
recruitment effectively so that was kind
of where the idea came from my we give
five percent of our profits to charity
as both seven we change it our every 12
months face to every seven days just
because of the legwork involved with it
effectively so that was kind of when the
concept of the business became clear on
my head mmm and I was one of their
differentiating factors yeah and we've
got quite a few like actual USP as a
business so I guess we're we would kind
of deliver the business of the community
driven business so we separate that into
the community we live in which is kind
of Bristol Bristol based so we'll give
five some of our profits to charity
we've donated $25,000 to different
charities and I Simone those two years
of business and every we're on within
the business of the volunteer with that
charity as well so we're not just
writing a check and ticking a box and
shuffling over a wall and never engaging
with that charity 3ns volunteer see what
impact is making in the local community
and then we created a group as well
called Bristol Technology volunteers
where there's a huge appetite in the
tech community for techies developers
whatever it may be that one that gifts
that time back
to charity but there was no platforms
and to do it so we focus our charity
contributions to small local charities
in Bristol that were typically raised
about hundred hundred and fifty K year
in funding so a our donation makes
assisting this contribution to that
charity but B because they don't raise
much funding their their IT systems
their website their volunteers platform
as an organization for it I was might
literally like prehistoric basically so
we noticed actually we're working and
partnering with charities that have got
some serious IT issues we've got a load
of IT people that we work with in our
community that want to volunteer so why
don't we just join the T's basically the
bristles technologies volunteers just we
engage with charities about what would
they love to do and then prove from an
IT point of view we put that out to
people in the tech community they kind
of put their hands up effective in say
I'll happily go and build changes a
brand new website and then we just join
the dots in the middle and say all right
off you go go and sort of mount activity
so those are kind of three key pillars
from a community that we live in and
then the community that we recruit
within is on the CIT so that's where we
get a lot of our time and our our
efforts on finances behind making sure
that tech community is thriving through
events and meet ups that we do lots of
the business yeah man that's awesome and
and so that there was sort of ideas that
you had before you might actually open
the doors or that's all evolved yeah but
I'd be lying if I said we had all of
those of those from day one so
definitely the charity P from the
volunteering piece that was clear the
tech common tears came just involved
just young yeah chances of those
meetings and then the event we certainly
do more than I perhaps plans to but they
just evolved over time to restart we
started with one in DevOps which was an
area that we do a lot of recruitment in
it was it was a meet-up that just laid
dormant in bristol no one has done
anything with it for like six months
that we just go in touch with it the
organizer basically just said I don't
have the time to do it if you want to
help me out with it and get it going
again then that would be great so we we
started with that one and we're now
involved in like ten different kinds of
stuff in a complete mix of things either
supporting someone else there's one
create our own ones or being asked to
help out like
okay really interesting I'm keen to
definitely get sort of them just you on
this for some perspective on the
marketing piece because I think that
from from what I can see externally and
I know what other people you I would see
it seems like you've done that really
well so I'm definitely gonna I'm
definitely not around the commercials on
that and then how it's actually impacted
your business commercially and these
types of things so I guess just real
just real practical things that I want
to ask you firstly and when you started
this business a lot of people are sort
of fearful of taking that initial leap
and making that jump
what what sort of like did what sore
runway did you give yourself to in terms
of light did you sort of work that our
war I don't know what cuz you I mean
you've got four people in quite early
which typically doesn't isn't the
typical case of a recruitment business
but is a typical case of those that want
to sort of grow quickly so I'm assuming
that Chris's mindset was you did this
was a business you wanted to grow first
and foremost yeah yeah what was the
wrong way that you gave yourself cuz I
think that's that's something I had to
come up with an important impact should
I have six months of sort of money where
I don't need to worry about Billings or
level what was your mindsets was that or
what did you have in place and think
about runway all the time even more so
now was a good and I guess my mindset
was always I'm gonna do where I want to
do it properly so it's always to build a
business that I could scale quite
quickly and bring people on that journey
with it and get people that are
ambitious and want to want to grow and
evolve with their company so I didn't
want to be just me in this little office
at home just you know I'm doing stuff I
wanted to see you knew that they were
mine yeah yeah so I get in terms of how
I funded the business first kind of
complete conference the odd when I first
left oasis and was going to start them
with my friends I'd we'd already been to
the bank had a bank loan in place and
got funding where I'd repay odd had
those means of the bank manager has them
come at the business plan presented
exercise effectively when I was ready
went back the same guy okay who I'd done
previously was like right now I'm ready
this is what it looks like so I had
funding a decent-sized funding pot from
them I then have I then took a loan will
we secured six figures
so I borrowed 80 grand secured my house
against alone with the banking board
80,000 pounds and I had 20 grand myself
and I borrowed 40 grand off my dad so
I've had literally hundreds of CERN's
grounds basically so a decent chunk I
said how much runway that gave us yeah
probably probably 12 months if we start
there and didn't do it here and that
would kind able us to be more than
comfortable to kind of grow it quite
aggressively which is the worst in the
plan yeah I mean that I mean that isn't
I mean that is again that's clearly
coming from a place of you this is a
business you on the scale right so I
guess
okay so just just to frame up then so
end of year one how many people didn't
end up at Evan seven it says seven of
you by the year one and as for all of
you quite but for review including you
quite early on and and what did you
finish on revenue wise or and a five a
year one we turned over picture state of
two million so GP 774 K in year one
yes it's less we talk about that because
some people and I mean a lot of
recruitment businesses early on don't
achieve that right so just quickly I
think a big part of this is sort of your
your mindset the money that you had and
how he was thinking about it so I guess
we've all with all that money then Chris
I think you hear and see a lot now where
it's like and sometimes when people have
all this funding that money it's just
easier to spend and so I guess what
rather than those the sort of blue strap
it or whatever and more careful their
money because they can't just spend
thousand thousand pounds whatever so I
guess from your perspective what you've
learned what were some of those sort of
key things that you invested in that
really enable you to hit those numbers
and sort of set you up to scale further
in year 2 a lot I'm talking tools I'm
talking if it may be a lot of that when
it's people I don't know what were some
of the sort of key things that have
ended up actually being really good
investments so hundred planet pools so
again in terms of my mind that doing it
properly I want to I didn't want to be
scrimping and saving on job boards or
advertising spend or links in the crew
all that sort of stuff so I was very
clear that I wanted to make sure you
give people
you got a best people you can which I've
had which I hadn't had the luxury of
knowing at least some nations even
working than Croesus again a best could
be you can give them the best tools and
the paddy environment he possibly can
the rest should look after itself in
theory we don't we didn't getting good
people not given the tools you're going
to come in problems so let's let what
were the best tools in your opinion and
or what I've become like the best tools
for you that have been great it's a
LinkedIn recruiter what what else have
been done the toolbox thing everyone
says podcast like bullhorn as a database
as a CRM used and broadbean and what
kind of multi job posts we used all the
job boards so literally you name it from
an IT perspective wasn't one that we
weren't used in from a monster read in
the usual suspect we had advertisements
initially in year one across all of
those as well and that's just some some
of the investments obviously when you're
starting you do have any ROI and
anything so my attitude was let's just
give able on the best of what they
probably don't can and then in year two
then we actually left make it what was I
return on that and in hindsight for
example my seed every job as we've
spending a fortune on adverse with them
and actually I returned wasn't that
great from it and we were getting more
from our own website than we work from
CW for example so we could be refining
living more further down the line but
certainly in the first twelve months
and I'm amazed looking back absolutely
would have wasted money on certain stuff
but okay I think if it's worthwhile said
and and what what percent like how much
do you spend on marketing in that first
year do you think percentage-wise was
your guy in stood you your gut say like
what board just like so you said so for
two million turnover what your profit
was I think one of the things that you
guys have done where's the branding the
marketing so I guess I don't know what's
just sort of gut saying like roughly
percent like how much of your yeah how
much money walk sent is wiser you spend
on marketing that sort of them
definitely would've helped you achieve
that but how much do you
roughly spend out amongst and you reckon
percentages rice at same
easily 7 AE grams yeah like comfortably
I think in terms of her it's a big chunk
of what your costs are and in our world
you can recruit really you can recruit a
telephone a laptop and a phone that's
literally all we need in theories you
want to kind of do it super lean you can
you can certainly do that and so it is a
big chunk of your costs and if I was if
I was doing it again and starting again
I'd be definitely something codes
reevaluate in terms of actually what do
we need and for example now some of the
job was we don't you know there's we
don't advertise across the mall because
we just won't get any response from them
yeah okay
that's interesting though and I mean
that's a pretty hefty number that I mean
some recruitment bases longer I've been
in business longer bigger men never
spend that sort of money on mark things
you know I mean so I guess how much
thought did you put into your brand you
had the narrative you had the charity
the social responsible which are things
awesome was that the only sort of pot I
don't know was that the only part of the
brand new you fought of because I think
like from the face of it it seems like I
don't know you've tried to be bit
different like if you look at your
website you've got a lot dogs everywhere
and like just different like you know I
mean so I guess how else how much did
you think about the marketing of SRT
besides the narrative and the story of
the this social responsible piece or was
that the main piece so I think things
like that when we started out so if you
again it goes back from one view to
doing things properly so I'm I'm not I'm
not good at marketing and not good at
branding I something that's not what
comes on my strengths so yes I had the
narrative on I came up with the name as
the best part - so she's lots of
recruitment once I had that a now the
ethos in terms of what I was trying to
create I then went to experts and went
to you outsource up to her a designer a
brand person said right this is on
trying to create go ahead and come up
with a come up with some branding behind
it and they came up with four or five
different ideas the narrative under the
dogs and stuff was was the one that
stood out for me because I wanted to do
something different there's no point
from my phone green just being another
agency that's doing exactly the same
like just pointless yeah and so we're
very clear in terms of one enter trying
maybe do you think a bit risky or
stunning out from the crowd certain e6
even like the content and the copy on
our website that's not been written by
me yeah yeah but I think I think a lot
of people it's a second floor
it's the second floor like you'd go
through that you know I mean I think
this is one I'm going to now it shows
Kinser our secret because I think this
is from what I'm understanding and know
about your business is probably what
you've done well is that I don't know
conversations you may or may have had
with other sort of recruitment business
owners is the typical times people can
fall in the mindset of light I'll do
I'll do that when I get to such-and-such
this milestone I'll do that I'll worry
about I want to get to X heads or when I
get 2x profit but clearly you're someone
that had the one so I'm gonna do it from
day one or do it as early as possible do
it properly to go I mean I think that's
what we need to talk about that because
some someone might have gone for that
process after they've done it for a year
and did you get Y min so I guess what
was some of the so I guess just to frame
up as well how many so was Chris's role
like was you just focus was rebilling or
was you just was your role very much
like make and maximize the people and
get the most other people you bring into
the business nice I mean day day one I
was I was billion so I haven't kind of
been hands-on on the tools trying to
bring that in for life I probably five
maybe six years and run some was
completely hands-off overs towards the
end in London was largely hands-off so
certainly five years whereas but when we
started with s4 tubes there was four of
us we had a database we had littering
and empty bullhorn with nothing on that
yeah we asked to like it was just roll
up his sleeves and try and get on it so
I first try one builder from giant
something but I mean because like first
the first six months is very much like
right let's all just go act it and build
what we can as much as we can you know
and once we kind of found our feed we
have some clients paying invoices we
could see well you a snake and so we
first deal took literally just less than
a month which is believe it or not me
and will you join us on that yeah
yes there's a trap there was pretty
crappy over anyway they will come from
the first one and our first invoice that
went out the door is quite funny looking
back in preparation for this office
invoice when I was or was was a hundred
some rebate job we said we faced like an
icy support female and some company lost
the share and she started on like a
Wednesday and then we come in on a
Monday morning going on is the first
invoice we spent now because my guy
didn't start until the next it until
2018 and they were like yeah we we've
had a rain we've got to get rid of it
because she'd literally taken a company
laptop home on the weekend and was on
material that she shouldn't have been on
base so he has to get rid of first
through like okay don't worry about that
and then after that then did it because
I feel like what I've saw gathered from
you is that your vet like your role is
very much more about really focusing on
the business yeah understand five safety
thirty first six months is all about run
s again let's get a wheels turn and yeah
get some money and get something turn
and once we build a client base and
stuff like that and you can see things
are moving in the right direction is
then very much went on to operational
strategical staff hiring has been a
property huge efforts of what we're
doing which were getting the right
people into business so first I was like
after six months then get her specimen
started in April which is five or six
months after we started you know we
finished the first year with seven seven
at home yeah okay cool so I guess so
then so then was it for my six month
onwards we're like you're sort of role
had then gone into like very much
strategic on the business and I'm sure
you doubled in there every now and again
but it's it's been a lot more focused on
the business and was that was the plan
because obviously that's good yeah a
hundred percent and I think that's
enabled us to grow quite fast I would
say because I'm my strength never was
the said of the star was never like a
mega Billa about yeah my place now I
mean to this kind of doesn't benefit the
business for me just beyond the tools
and year-3 still trying to fund all
three 150k I was just kind of no point
in that say I think
we can do that the quicker we just start
to scale the business and put things in
place to do so so having been equally
artists it was really fortunate having
Alecia nation Steve from the outset
they're all very experienced very good
sailors very good at what they do they
could crack on without and look after
the sales other things than I like could
actually focus on the businesses yeah
yeah I mean that makes sense of that
that's had an impact I guess just a
quick one before we sort of go into that
journey then is did you did everyone
know that like did you over communicate
that look guys you know I'm not the best
Billa I will I'm rolling up my sleeves
let's do this bar just so you all know
this is sort of where I want to be
yeah probably pretty obvious yes from
the outset I mean that said they cease
work they've worked with me around for
the he here what my role was and what
the strengths presences of what we could
what we did there so that was very much
ambition so there was never any
questions of that and we have no one
from a back office point of view so
anything in terms of invoicing and
payroll and all that sort of malarkey
that that was me I was everything
back-office marketing of your place all
that sort of stuff so as you grow
another gets bigger and more stuff going
on with more moving parts it starts to
suck up a lot of time so I was gradually
doing might ease away from from it
naturally just because of all the other
things that were going on even events
and stuff like that take time organizing
and the logistics of Burma it all takes
tie in fact yeah yeah sure okay no I
just think that that's interesting
because I think a lot of businesses that
are that sort of size is the business
owner typically just really feels like
that they'll they're never going to be
able to sort of get their head above the
water and beyond the business and but I
think clearly what you've done well is
is made sure that one you communicate
that that's what your plan is going to
be and also you get the people around
you to do and what will see their great
art in terms of billing sales blah blah
blah and you pick up the rest so I guess
let's really talk about that journey
then in in groaners business so it seems
like year one and had a great platform
then to grow this business further I
guess what we're sort of going
two year two then Chris what were some
of the sort of key learnings
I mean clearly had a good great start
right with which house which no doubt
filled you with confidence yes so I
guess what were the sort of key
learnings going into that year to where
you're like right we did this really
well in year one or this is a big part
as to why we managed to get to where we
did in year one that you're like right
we need to building this now and what
what was your sort of mindset going into
year two it was very much so we finished
here two on sixteen people so the kind
of focus was definitely headcount growth
in terms of what we're doing his work in
the brand was landing really well with
clients and customers we were finding it
pretty easy I would say to win new
business and bring customers on it was
attracting kind of lots of interests
there the meet up some events we started
doing again it's kind of been working
really well for us day there was nothing
that we weren't like here to like for
analyst drops outlets a bit more times
doing this it was just a gated but
double down doing more at the same of
what we're doing so we went we're never
trying to reinvent the wheel I think
it's really becoming a recruitment it's
actually quite a simple thing it was
just like let's do the basics well let's
give people in right environment to work
in and get the best out of people and
let's just work about closed off and
kind of build it from there so was there
was nothing revolutionary we did in year
two that we hadn't already begun in year
one it was just more of the same so more
of the other things that we're doing
more there were more events there was
more of a focus on women rock that
Alicia was kind of doing successfully in
terms of diversity inclusion of those
just uses more of the same yeah okay so
I mean whenever we've spoken I feel like
what what you've been good at is really
is being able to UM hire good people for
your recruitment business and a nose and
and that's obviously a real common
challenge for a lot of recruitment
businesses right so I guess let's
definitely talk about that for a second
terms your learnings for that because it
seems like that obviously your past
you've probably learned so much in just
getting better at sort of what to look
out for what not to look for and then
these types of things so I guess and to
tie in with that
well I should know yet let's just focus
on that I guess like in terms of going
from basically doubling the headcount
which a lot of people struggle to do and
then struggle to push past that 910 head
and head count mark etc like what was
you just did you just like did you just
hire one after the other did you hire a
group of people together what what was
the actual hiring strategy was your
mentality of we're always hiring you're
always meeting people what was the
mindset
so we've never I think I've only ever
hired two people at one time in terms of
two people on the same day where the
strategy was always together experienced
people and then because I just I didn't
have the same you didn't have they're
trying no we'd have the time did you
have any idea number time to train
people from scratch and tons of those
personas hey xylophone number we just
didn't have the capability to do it and
all the time to do out the capability
but that that was a that was definitely
a strategy so our kind of sweet spot has
been people that are like three months
to twelve months experience so people
that have maybe gone into a company and
to accompany it's not been the right
cultures there or having maybe
necessarily seen any success at all and
then we've maybe picked them up as much
job job to basically yeah and so there's
no other people that you don't need to
teach the fundamentals to but there are
also people that maybe on stuck in their
ways or thinking are what we used to do
like that they're the kind of people
that still open still want to learn
still hungry because if they fail
somewhere else that still want to make
successful in recruitment and they still
want some fire in their belly as well so
the fact majority of say over half of
the people in our office of all those
people that was fit into that second job
type degree three months twelve months
experience for them we can work with it
how did it how did you get these people
like the Jews rhetorics did you yeah
that's right I I've only used the rector
act once in two-and-a-half years and not
because I wouldn't and that because I
think I'm probably sees busy on LinkedIn
in terms of like I always say like just
nosy I think I hiring and finding people
and getting people
Chester Dan in screeners probably I
would say my main strength though they
doing that so I was always even now like
once a week I was gone the job boards
and I'll do kind of like what recruiters
are on the job boards over the last week
so I was picked up a couple of people
that comes from that means they're my
dupatta CBR thinking I'm not happy I'm
okay so you're always looking yeah
always looking and LinkedIn I said I'm
all the way to kind of message people
directly if ever anyone looks at me on
LinkedIn locally so I think might be bin
chef and I always follow up the message
of your life I wouldn't be like oh honey
I've seen like you start some level of
engagement in terms of the conversation
okay and then my time if I haven't done
that you then see that person's left
that company and has gone summarize my
bike downloads back and why they like it
and but I think you should always be
interview and whether you're hiring or
not in my opinion something you can gain
so much more from it in terms of what's
going on in the marketplace and even if
you're interviewing people you might not
think could be the perfect city of
business a they might end up being but B
even if you don't you can still get some
sort of nugget of information you might
then lead to a good hire okay yeah I
mean oh yeah since you wouldn't right
and I think the way you've ended up
stretching your business and the people
you got in to is a neighborhood because
I think that's what business owners
don't have the time to do so that is
like that is obviously how do you do
other stuff it's not completely takes
your full bandwidth for what Chris does
but I'm sure that's a good chunk of your
time and what you're doing especially if
you have those obviously aggressive
numbers and you'll spend a lot of time
on that so I guess I mean from nice
Oregon I think the brand has been far
more kind of powerful than maybe I would
have first thought as well so we do get
a lot of people a lot of likes and a lot
of our people have just applied directly
or emailed yes 2001 it's in email but in
power and mayavadi fingers I think it
just like for me it's a fight I think
it's we certainly come across and I was
hope you come across a just authentic in
terms of what we do so our industry
doesn't have the greatest reputation
everyone knows there are some great
people in our industry but equally
insane
industry with with with hard with the
kind of estate agent car salesman part
mentality so I think if you can create
something it stands out is authentic and
genuine to show that actually you're not
a [ __ ] you care about what you do
you care about you and you're seen wanna
make a positive impact in it you will
stand out so I think those it kind of
goes back to creating a business that I
would want to work in myself so the no
case we are culture is really good and I
think that we do this kind of
transferring that culture through our
social channels for example yeah I've
had plenty of people come to as an
interview and be like my words I'd like
to work there as something they looked
at they're too good to be true
something I've heard my profile that's
what that's what I mean that was one
next thing because I think that's what
you've done you guys have done well
strategically or not strategically I
think it's probably a bit mixture of
both it sounds like that you you just
you guys just got good at communicate
and what you guys are up to what you
like online and ultimately I think when
I look at you and your team and your
business I think from an internal
standpoint I think you just look really
human and I think there's a Sony
recruitment businesses that don't look
human and and they're so worried about
sort of how they come across and all
this but you guys yes it's the authentic
piece but I guess that that was my net
increase because I think having met a
couple of people from your business I
think that's all great if you can do
that but if that doesn't translate into
actual real life then it's [ __ ]
pointless so I guess you must have been
instrumental along with obviously the
early people that joined you on sort of
what was the strategy or what what how
have you saw cultivated that culture I
guess a big part of that is making sure
that the people you're bringing in our
show indicators or show things that are
in line like what what have you done to
ensure that people adding to the culture
rather than taken away from it
yes I think 100% my mindset would always
but I mean obviously people have their
own intricacies in there and they're in
little quirks naturally but I think
people's core beliefs in fundamentals in
terms of what good were criminals like
or what their life is a person needs to
fit into our culture so I've interviews
like even like top pillows or other
companies like to 50-plus pillars I mean
to be a couple examples I kids I could
think of and great villas and the
numbers commercially was clearly
obviously as a but culturally they just
wouldn't fit into our business and I
might add a 250 biller but I'm gonna
lose 300 100 20 capability emoji I
wouldn't make sense though the waste cut
our culture ahead of and our people
ahead of kind of anything commercially
from that point of view so I think we've
been very good at finding the right type
of characters that aren't your
stereotypical recruitment type people
anyone that's kind of interested in
purely themselves and just inches no
much money's in that bank and just not
gonna fit into our business and I'm just
going to be highest but he wouldn't fit
with we're very kind of picky I would
say in terms of who we do - we do hire
and who does kind of make it in so that
they won and I think it's work and was
you always like that or is that
something that you just had to become
really strict on it slow if you're it's
very different when you're spending your
own money so like I can they get runs up
days where where the objective was grow
grow grow grow grow I was given a P&L
and targets which is really super
aggressive and they might be like forty
five people and I'm looking at anything
oh I've only got 20 people so I forgot
to get 25 people in my business area say
P in order to get that target I don't
really think I'm ever going to hit so
you can almost be like pulling in
different directions so I can look back
at people are hired there and you just
think okay that was in the stage and
just naturally with experience you learn
as you go in terms of what's going to
fit what's gonna work and I still don't
get everything right no one I didn't do
a course we hired people with are people
you're never going to get everything
right I think our success rate
lefferts's been like really high our
retention has been really high we've
lost in
like 31 months legislated two and a half
years we lost six people three people
have resigns one of those is to go and
become a chef and two went internally at
one of our clients I've never left I've
never lost anyone to another recruitment
agency and the other three people I kind
of actually because they weren't kind of
up to standard injuries effectively so
our attention has been pretty good but
even you see still means they can show
us they'll make further ones in the
future no I think we're quite picky in
terms of who we gave for and making sure
that culture fit is always right for us
for the visitor so let's just talk about
that for a second then and leading up to
now as well what what things have you
done because it's because that's the
other part actually then keeping the
good people in your business and I think
that that can be quite challenging when
you're in a sort of smaller growing
business because obviously everyone
wants career progression everyone wants
to know that there's great opportunities
in the business that they're in and
sometimes that can be quite hard to
understand or think about how you can
make your employees think or understand
what the opportunities are so I guess
what what do you think are the things
that you got you you guys have done well
or implemented that really impacted the
retention of your good people do you
think like number one just probably
treat people in the right in in the
right way number one so we we just
certainly don't pay the world's greatest
salaries I'm sure those companies
they'll have kind of bigger bigger
wallets from those where we've got
really good and competitive commission
structure we we kind of are as flexible
as possible in terms of late start early
finishes creating an environment where
we don't have tape we don't API then
manage my numbers we give people
autonomy we give them the tools to be as
the customers it can be we obviously
support people but in terms of day to
day is very much the kind of ethos is
set people up in the right way and then
just give people their the economy
autonomy to go about the job in the way
they want Sooners and if people are on
the same page in terms of have an
ambition to want to be successful and do
a decent job and you create the right
environment for them to thrive then I
mean why would people want to leave your
business if that's in
except hmm where that will always be the
same in terms as we grow and you know
everyone we hired fit into that culture
now we've got more junior people as I
said how we would manage and most face
we say more junior people might be
different and more seniors but we've
hired some really successful principal
people that have come and done a great
job and that literally wouldn't ever
have any conversations in terms of
day-to-day and other than kind of what
anything needs people need to call with
so I think culturally is very much the
case of just treat people like adults
treat people respect given the
environment the need to thrive and kind
of let them give them the space to do so
sounds simple done it but sorry people
before we don't just think about it that
way so um so how did you finish in your
to then Chris in terms of so you got you
had obviously said it's about 17 heads
what obviously were always keen to
understand profitability and what that
means because headcount isn't always the
right barometer of how well we couldn't
mrs. dent but how can you finish up year
2 then thirdly 2019 we did 3.3 for 1
million turnover that was one point
three one five in GP and that was just
over a million and perm GP and we did
terms in 57k and contact GP and that was
becoming 16 had 16 heads okay so all
sounds great at growing doing the right
finger walk what's been the biggest
challenge for you Chris mindful of that
we spoke a lot about the positives and
like what what what what have been I
could even talk about now if it's now
but what would have been the the biggest
challenges for you and things yeah um
there's not think about this obviously
in preparation there isn't like one
thing I could think of and be like no
there are little things I could think of
like operationally I've got wrong so the
the big there's probably two big things
that stand out for me which cost as
money I would say who I see an
infrastructure from day one and I just I
didn't I relied on someone that I
thought I could rely on in terms of the
provider I went to and it took me
probably nine or ten months of pain
realize that actually I was getting
complete
flea stand some of the what I must the
waste of 10 I'll just paint at least
double what I should have and could have
been paying and the dilution was crap
anyway so I remember stretchable than
what it was and that was just my naivety
I only going to once the fire I knew
them for a decent job they didn't for
that it cost probably placed easily 10
grams to us and then I think the second
lesson would a hundred percent been
around the terms of terms of business so
obviously as every company start she
kind of your terms of business hopefully
and I've been a lot of mishmash of
perhaps wave word previously and we
don't like to look on a fudge together I
come yes so basically they just move
were not strong so we probably had I
think when you're when you're spark on
your new business there are the vast
majority of people want to help you want
to support you and will do a good go out
a way to make sure they eat you growing
you eat survive and which is amazing on
the flip side of that there probably is
a smaller portion of people that will
take it advantage and I think we've
probably had five or six now blood
actually breaks and backdoor situations
and then when it actually comes to the
crunch and I've looked are terms of
business and you like actually there's
no way in the world that should be
allowed to happen but then you like
actually look at the black and white
from a legal point of view with over
this list and you look at your terms is
like actually be the pony like very down
and then like they're just not going to
stand up so that's been a lesson so I
said we reinvested and had solicited
would you would you have done would you
have done that to begin and then what
yet probably cost me 40 50 grand and
fees that we should have had that we
haven't yeah yeah interesting someone
messing me about that sounds like really
mundane and boring but somebody's
messing live you've got any content on
spoke to them about some of the business
because I think it's things like you
just said can happen and sort of it as
you said it can be a mishmash at the
beginning it should like people like
what you're sort of bit night I've
probably been I'll be honest I only
actually got my clients to sign a
contract three months ago
yeah before that I was just sending
invoices and a PDF document I got a
Haitian will do that so it's
you solve I don't know because you ended
up I don't know people just like yet
Chris sounds brain would do it and yeah
like you have probably way more insert
incidences where they get they do get
paid and it's all good but it's those
couple that happen that [ __ ] you know we
definitely to get the solid yeah and you
never know and who you need it until you
need it like it and said we'd do it so
would you would you swallow the payment
and get it done sooner rather than later
would be the advice yeah yeah I mean if
well it's what it works out okay for us
because equally it is this kind of a
learning process that we we have things
like kind of decent if in terms about
our rebate period with a free
replacement yeah that enabled us from a
cash flow point of view as we were
growing and says to not be shelling out
if we did I mean we had less than 3% of
our placements in our time of actually
been a rebase it's like huge issues of
businesses we've got really good kind of
attention to our placements but it
didn't mean that if something did go
wrong then we weren't actually having to
give cash back out of the cash flow we
were just having to go back back back to
square one and kind of work again today
there was some like intricacies of them
have worked really well so but I mean
certainly if I could do it again I was
definitely kind of do the boring legwork
and get them done properly as we have
now done but so there's that other than
those two things those are probably to
teach some other things I could
physically go they'd cost of my console
yeah yeah okay so as we come to the end
of this centrist what's been going on in
your world over the last eight to twelve
weeks or eight weeks what how
obviously she's see you've been really
open line service on wake up to you in
the business here to you're halfway into
your third year probably sort of bit
frustrated because I've heard it so many
times I the last couple of weeks we had
our best quarter was on the plan to do
this this this Julie you've sort of fed
into that I guess what what yeah what's
been going on in your world over the
last eight weeks as you said we've had
February was our best one server we've
done as March and we've done another
twenty two percent obvious we literally
have February and March best both from
an invoice on a kind of new business
point of view so in a good spot and then
obviously it
London sui I feel like where we are now
like we're in a good spot as a business
there we hit we have summarized to make
some kind of difficult decisions and
certainly most decisions have mates and
start on the business so what do you
mean like one so I think we were quickly
quite quickly to get people working from
home and be fully remote and then we did
that as a business as a whole for
certainly a couple of weeks but then
obviously there's once the furlough
situation so I put a severe 18 people
were 8 people are on furlough which was
either the more junior people in the
business office manager like back-office
support resource junior people or one
person that just recently switched
markets so there's kind of patch remit
established enough for them to kind of
have a decent client base and still be
hiring so that was a difficult position
obviously we are effectively self funded
startups so yes we've had a lot of
success I think in hindsight social
example there the business loan I took
was a three year loan that were paid off
in two years the money I borrowed off my
dad was a three year loan that I paid
off in 18 months as a business we was
debt-free but I was really keen trying
to pay them off as quickly as possible
which then has an impact on what cash
she's got for the year so naturally my
first thought was let's look at the cash
flow like you can run a business on loss
for the Quattro quite some time that
you're only going to run out of cash one
so once the severity of the situation
happened and a furlough had to be done
and then we made the decision of those
that were left we were going to defer
Commission payments because our
Commission is very good with shelling
out 35 40 grand a month in Commission
it's a big way of I was kind of adding
to the runway effectively so Mason made
the decision to the guys that we would
just was still pay them but would just
defer that Commission and not depend how
into how was that receiving us amazing
leaders like I said it was obviously not
a conversation I would want to be having
with them but I think there are seven is
anything like that we just kind of walks
them through the full process on
perfectly transpire in terms of this is
our this is our position as a business
this is our thought process behind why
we're doing it the end goal is that we
protect the
there's still a job here for you and at
the end of it I think the way the way
it's played out was and said everyone
took it really well it's literally no
question mark later and one of the lads
Jack remember messaged me when I was
kind of walking back to the car like
15-minute walk back to the car that
night and I was about 8 o'clock what
time I was walking back after kind of
sharing the message and it was the next
day we were all fully remote as kind of
a last opportunity I had of everyone
being all together and something not a
good conversation you want to have them
people but Jack had messaged me saying a
hundred percent the right thing to do
like the protecting the business making
sure were here like 100 summer I was
just literally starting the car parking
my car just waiting back a little baby
yeah how did nothing but I think I think
they challenged then the love sort of
why obvious because people's in again
that balance with the people did our
work in do not I mean like have you have
you then been open and honest about are
they getting their Commission deferred
or they you have to take do you not I
mean yeah how do you have you balance at
because I think that's where some songs
that could be friction and then Jack
McGann I know what we have to do but
it's bit unfair the the guys that are
working did you not I mean how did you
approach that same for everyone yeah see
that's the thing yeah got so everyone on
everyone on furloughs been topped up to
so we paid it to 20 percent so
everyone's got a hundred others salary
and the deferred Commission's did for
everyone whether you're on furlough or
not everyone will also get that money so
it's not as if we're saying right we're
just cancelling Commission yeah thing as
they will get that money everyone has a
confidence and nose in the business that
we're we're going to do we're going to
do so so yeah I'm the same with any
decision needs to be made you can't do
something for one not for everyone it's
gotta be the same for every one other
way you can just get some problems and
that goes back to your the kind of
authenticity or have an open honest from
conversation communication with people
use if you tell people how it is and
there's no lies and you're not going to
get you out from the done right yeah and
I think I've see one of the things that
you shared with us on this is the clear
something really passionate and proud
about is is the culture and the people
you have in the business how have you
gone about again I think that's been a
real common challenge of people light so
you've got the bench of people and
further but the bench people
King how you ensure that there isn't
that sort of divide of sort of [ __ ] a
lot from the people that are working
it's all right for them they're watching
Netflix all day watching Tiger King
today is a riot compared to the guys and
fellow you know I mean thinking about
[ __ ] now they've got the call-up I
didn't I'm not good enough I think
that's that's an interesting balance
right so I guess what have been some of
the things that you've done to make sure
that there's still that togetherness and
the culture that you've worked really
hard to do but remotely so I guess I
lost my goal was just to try and
replicate the normal office environment
and culture as much as possible remotely
so I've sent again never had any
conversations from any friction between
for those people but non furloughed
people but that kind of goes back to
hiring them right up yeah exactly but
probably on a mindset uh but never
something never been shared with myself
but we do things are the group add in
everyone on the business so every Friday
afternoon will do the kind of teams
video stuff and do like we didn't race
in last week or will do because as every
business is doing say we do everyone at
least once a week is doing everything as
a team to kind of keep that mentality
together and keep sharing what's going
on and you will do like a round-robin 30
seconds what you've done for your week
and one of the last people people talk
about what it doesn't work or quite as
people that watch Netflix all day then
fair and what's been done because I
think that the other sort of speak to a
business owner about this this week I
think the other balance and that is then
like have you like communicate any
expectation of your staff who are on
furlough tonight I'm in crime I think
it's of even I think it's gonna be a
valid question which is what did you get
to infer like even from lucky me
recruiter and I'm working with Talan and
they're on foot luncheon I mean that's
going to be an interview that's gonna be
an interview question what do you do on
furlough so like I don't know have you
have you put any expectations on little
bit great guys if you could do this like
you know you've seen all these self
development learning blah blah blah
what's been your approach on that and so
we a we keep in touch to them regularly
so it's not as if they're just kind of
thirds and we don't sort on for ten
weeks however though they were send kind
of from day one we put together like the
things that they could do so weather
Skillshare what just i think i and your
your phrase from one of your things
about keeping match fit well that be
skilled chefs that's whether that be
personal branding we sent out reading
lists or people to follow just to read
that's just people people can keep
engaging quite a lot of people have done
that one of the guys was books yesterday
is start to learn Python programming and
he's trying to create a commission
calculator for us when we would learn
but just pump it like stuff I think some
people took it other people are flower
doing Cortney black fitness sessions and
they're going to come back rip to pieces
I think and so like there's no question
what people want to do like we're
engaging with them if they want to do
cell phone or something entree if they
don't and know how she do what you wanna
get you're never gonna get this
opportunity again are you yeah not fair
I think is is optional I think there's
just a challenge there way like if you
put someone on furlough and then expect
them to like use that all that time
productively and efficiently not sure
about that yes yes I think that's been
the challenge so I guess okay so I guess
look finger obviously as we went through
this talking about your business journey
up until now what I know obviously when
we before we put this in your viewers
really keen to you really felt like you
haven't achieved a whole lot I wanted to
sort of wait to reach certain milestones
but I guess sort of a lot of people here
this all numbers you're hitting the
thing they may see online what you're
doing baba blah and then will really
sort of have a perception of that you
guys are doing really well but I guess
from your from your experience and the
learnings over the last two notes in the
bit years what what do you think has has
sort of been really important that's
enabled you to sort of build the
platform and sort of have to and
hopefully another third successful year
do you think well have been the sort of
key things that have really enabled you
to do that
would you say to sort of wrap this up
people yeah I think like we like our
kind of ethos is very much people own
profits so you put your people first
hires it doesn't matter how good our
brand was if we could still have SRC if
we are rubbish people in the team and
the business we would do rubbish it's
that simple so it's the quality of
people that you hire
the qualities people and then retaining
and motivating keeping these people
happy is the absolute key in what we do
so I think for us to keep scaling and
keep growing and reach our ambitions and
it is all about identifying more and
more and more of these kind of good
people they're going to fix it with our
resource and stuff but it doesn't
permeate doesn't matter what you do with
your business in terms your steps and
stuff it's about making your people as
good as they can be and how to get is
hiring the best people you possibly can
up the that's the name of the game for
me mmm where would you like to see sr2
what's the sort of vision and the next
two and a half years then and we've done
a lot of things on our agenda at the
mentees that still grow in so I think
our kind of aim with Bristol would be
skipper it's those kind of 4050 people
we've started as of 2020 doing Europe so
we've started this kind of Berlin
function and it's time to build out to
Steve one of our co-founders is doing
that and we're launching a new product
in the next couple of like early June
called how to scale which is going to be
like a subscription service requires and
so where we are kind of diversifying our
offer and we've talked about on the
statement of work and consultancy piece
as well so I'm very conscious of not
trying to kind of do too much yeah and
but equally there are lots of things
that we want to be doing as a business I
think we've been quite successful with
trying new things and if it doesn't work
just fail fast for that so there's lots
of things that we're now doing that
maybe weren't in the business plan at
the start that's been really successful
so there's there's lots of do new
different things in the pipeline of
various stages that are exciting but
ultimately will lend itself to growing
and growing the business growing the
headcount obviously as you say grow and
grow an extra GP that were doing
I love that so what what and before I
shall are the last question what are you
most excited about or most excited to do
after covered after we go down what you
most excited about not just whatever
whatever comes up and personal
professional I get personal I've got my
wife's pregnant at the moment so we've
got a three-year-old
he just got a puppy and then we've got a
newborn on the way in July the 4th so
that's pretty much number one call right
at the moment it's a little personal
point of view and I think from a
professional point of view is to get and
everyone back in the office and trying
to get some level of normality together
I think it's like you do miss that I
think everyone send it in our office
like everyone just misses that
camaraderie when the office and being
around leave me alone because I say how
culture is strong so people do then miss
it you know that for absolute key I mean
it's gonna be a challenge for fitting
everyone than the office would have to
meet a distance and that yeah well I
think we're gonna do like half and half
of this my three outside people named
Mike yeah I suppose a lot of people
don't think of that and last question
Chris so if you could communicate every
single recruiter out there they'd listen
they take on your advice it could be a
word a phrase a sentence what what would
you say to the people if they're that if
they're listening what what would Chris
say when you start a point of view just
just in general like if you could
communicate every single recruit out
there that would take on your advice
listen what what would your message be
as I say baby I'm just like this to see
yourself like being authentic I think if
you are being yourself you'll naturally
being authentic and people will buy in
your people quite some people people
people will buy into more you'll be more
genuine and just naturally be more
authentic I think too many people try
and either be someone and all companies
will try and create like recruitment
robots out of people but for me it's
just like be yourself be authentic and
people will naturally tend to gravitate
more towards that and someone who's
trying to put on a show or beat on that
or not I think of moving now awesome
Chris on has it been a pleasure and
really excited to see where you guys are
in the next two and a half years
definitely have to do this again
hopefully face to face and then that's
been actually pleasure Chris thank you
cool no way